nous avons la canne à sucre non la can
c'est sucré c'est à dire que quand c'est
bien ici tu dis c'est sucré et la canne
à sucre et ça veut dire que la can se
passe bien tout mon kiff quoi
je me souviens
d'une grosse fête je me souviens
de la chanson officielle
écrite par manu dibango nous souvient
des moments où j'allais avec papa voilà
on allait tous les deux au stade me
souviens la joie qu'on avait eue pendant
les premiers tours je me souviens de la
détresse intense qu'on avait perdu en
demi finale
mais ça reste un très très beau souvenir
parce que c'était le stade qui s'appelle
maintenant ahmadou ahidjo c'était
énorme stade il était tout nouveau
officiellement c'était 60 mille ou
soixante dix mille places
y avait cent mille personnes
les années d'avant ont joué un endroit
que ça plaise pas militaires ont joué
sur les matchs officiels quasiment sûr
de la terre avec des tribunes en bois
incroyable donc c'était le rêve de voir
un stade paris voit ses souvenirs que
j'ai ça fait longtemps que ça fait 50
ans
c'est un sentiment à la fois de
fierté parce que pour l'instant ça se
passe très bien l'idée c'est de faire
découvrir le pays a des gens qui sont
jamais venus et qui à travers le foot va
découvrir ce pays
que cris bola au cameroun c'est tout
quoi c'est vraiment où les gens vivent
vraiment rythme des résultats des lions
indomptables quand gagner un jour férié
le lendemain quoi donc le foot a un
pouvoir
de donner du bonheur incroyable aux gens
les lions indomptables c'est la fierté
du pays
les camerounais sont résistants
les camerounais
malgré le fait qu'il ya des problèmes
trouvent toujours au dernier moment une
solution quand on devient impossible
n'est pas camerounais c'est un peu ça on
a toutes les raisons de se diviser dans
ce prix mais on reste qu'un ensemble et
ça c'est donc voilà on est indomptables
face à l'adversaire mais aussi face à
l'adversité
c'est beau c'est ma vie c'est ma vie
papa était joueur de foot
je suis fan de foot j'aime beaucoup ce
sport parce que c'est le sport
universel par excellence tu peux aller
dans n'importe quel pays du monde
il ya un ballon tu te fais des potes tu
fais une passe décisif à un pote
mexicain c'est ton meilleur ami quoi
parce que vous embrassez moi je trouve
qu'il ya pas un sport qui a ce pouvoir
je suis footballeur je fais partie des
lions dans ma tête dans mes rêves
papa joue au foot papa était un lion
souvent j'ai zappé à part la lajemmerais
j'aurais tellement voulu
[Musique]
participer être dans une équipe faire un
sport d'équipé
diois yann c'est super mais toi tu as
une chance inouïe c'est que tu as ton
destin entre les mains tu dépends de
personne et quand tu déconnes de settat
faute quoi mais quand tu gagnes c'est
ton boulot c'est beau une victoire j'ai
déjà eu des moments de gloire en tant
que joueur en tant que capitaine mais
quand tu marques un but quoi
qu'est ce que c'est de marquer un but en
finale de la can
ça marche
seul dans une pièce avec personnes
autour comme casse pas les
jeux trop nerveux parce que je souffre
en fait pendant les matches je souffre
c'est une souffrance pour notre style
alors c'est un peu faire rigoler les
gens avec tous les matchs qu'il a vu
tout ce qu'il a fait dans sa vie doit
que nous sommes en jeu je sais trop quoi
c'est trop
on parle beaucoup du capitaine et du
cameroun au delà de son jeu j'aime
beaucoup qui il est j'aime beaucoup ce
qui l'amène j'aime beaucoup
ces réactions d'après match d'avant
match c'est logique c'est structuré
c'est fort c'est le capitaine c'est
notre capitaine
par roger milla à l'époque c'était
il a tellement fait de par son jeu yabo
ya des millions de gens qui ont
découvert que le cameroun ce n'est pas
une île grâce à roger
samuel
samuel à un niveau incroyable
samuel m'a beaucoup inspiré m'a donné
beaucoup de bonheur
si le cameroun gagne la can
je veux face je veux pas mettre le
mauvais oeil
nous devons d'abord gagner la
demi-finale
[Musique]